that's why that person within us little
boy little girl
why they have such a seat at the table
because they come to our world in a
they go hello who is it
it's a it's seven-year-old Pete it's
six-year-old Gary I got something to
tell you really why do you have to come
and sit down I'm going to make you some
hors d'oeuvres you want a do you
want something to drink what are you
telling me well if you do this you're
going to be rejected you're going to be
alone the rest of your life no one's
ever going to love you we think that
they are give they are the word of God
right they are Moses at the burning bush
yeah thou will be alone for the rest
like Jesus Christ yeah yeah so that's
why we listen and so what we do a lot of
times is we say why am I being so stupid
what's wrong with me which only
validates that that Young Person's voice
it only validates his hideousness which
actually makes him stronger in the
negative yeah does that make sense yeah
yeah so instead of doing that what I've
what I've thought I think is a really
great response instead of saying why do
I do that because whenever anyone gives
me like a why like what why are you
wearing this shirt Gary it's always a
bad question because I have bad taste
like there's never a good answer for
that right so instead of saying why
try this how interesting that I do this
yeah how interesting that I feel just
notice that because then we have a sense
of hmm let me explore it yeah little
Gary wouldn't say how interesting would
do that but so that's why it's so
powerful these voices within us